yoyoyo Billy Joe it's time to rock and
roll
scotch game style this is in addition to
our chess openings playlist if you
haven't watched all of them then what
else are you doing with your life I'd
like to know because it probably is more
fun than making chess videos and
watching them all day long
any hooters let's talk about the scotch
game which is one of White's most
aggressive ways to challenge the center
a much more direct approach to the
opening the first age of the game than
the Spanish the roy lopez which of
course we have opening lecture videos on
the spanish in our chess openings
playlist and of course there's the four
nights which we also covered as well as
the italian game which i do not believe
we have covered yet but will the
scotches is actually my opening so I
looked at our playlist and realize that
we don't even have a video lecture on my
particular repertoire which I guess is a
it's blasphemy so I said no more no more
shall we ignore the obvious which is
that the scotch game is the best way for
white to play e4 that's right I said it
just go ahead and try to prove me wrong
anyway the thing about the Scotch that's
most exciting is that it puts more
pressure on your opponent it's not it's
not as study deeply as the Spanish or as
well known at the beginner level is like
the Italian game or the fried liver
attacks and the gioco pianos it's it's
but it's a very solid way for white to
play favorite of Kasparov in the late
80s and all through the early to mid 90s
and after blacks best approach which is
of course to take the pawn white
captures back and black has a few
different ways to approach it the first
and most common is probably the most
principled which is the classical the
move Bishop to c5 simply brings another
attacker to the dark squares in the
center and it makes a lot of sense
because if your opponent being white is
going to open the center that quickly
you want to make an effort to fight
equally for those squares after Bishop
to c5 White has two ways to approach the
position I can take on c6 or I can try
to support taking on c6 essentially
relieves the pressure in the center and
sort of concedes victory to black in the
sense that black will get more control
over the dark squares after the
intermezzo Queen to f6 black is
threatening checkmate and so white
defends the pawn on f2 and after black
takes back we have sort of a
a similar structure to a rural Lopez or
a Spanish exchange which is that white
has a positional edge on the kingside
four pawns versus three and we'll play
for this sort of long-term advantage in
the middle game in into the endgame but
black has a small leading development in
compensation for black does not have the
bishop pair but after Knight to c3
Bishop e6 we can see blacks pieces
coming into the center very easily with
good control of the dark squares the
knight will develop and castles and so
because of that white usually tries to
do something directly to challenge it
this move Knight a4 is an interesting
approach for white I suggest those who
know the opening well enough to study it
you look into this move and after ninety
seven white will sometimes relieve the
pressure because being behind
development as I highlighted with a move
like queen up for offering the endgame
or offering a ton of fun with some pawn
grabbin pawn grab and stuff right don't
go grabbing my pawn I think I think that
makes sense
Knight takes c6 is a line that I
probably played more often than not but
Bishop to e3 is perhaps the more
principled approach for white to
continue to increase control over the
center instead of relieving the pressure
and after Queen f6 white usually plays
c3 the line with 90 to b5 of blumenfield
gambit is an exciting one and again if
you're out there and you're actually a
scotch game player you can look into
that as a fun weapon to have especially
in blitz and rapid chess but after c3
and 97 White has two main approaches he
did Bishop to c4 to prevent d5 get
castled and take the approach that
Kasparov and even more recently magnus
carlsen have played when playing the
Scotch or you can even play the g3
variation where the bishop tries to take
a more positional approach long-term the
bishop likes this diagonal but the risk
behind this move is that black can
challenge with c5 strike very early in
the center of the Bishop to c4 prevents
so again you can look into all those
variations if you wish to do so
a more recent try for white rather than
Knight takes c6 and Bishop e3 is this
interesting move Knight to b3 which
voluntarily moves the piece twice in the
opening but White has an idea of
developing the Queen side rather quickly
the bishop either coming to e3 or to g5
and even casting long again it's an
interesting variation from white that if
you are really considering making the
Scotch game a part of your repertoire I
would recommend looking into that the
sharpest approach for black is the mices
variation which rather
in the classical Knight f6 puts pressure
on e4 and sort of punishes White's
direct approach of opening the centre a
different way if Black has his way he
will continue to develop his pieces with
Tempe all surrounding the e4 pawn by
putting pressure due to the pin because
of that black dozen white doesn't want
to play nicely between allowed Bishop
before which is perfectly playable by
the way it would be a transposition into
sort of a four night scotch game but the
most accurate way for white to approach
the position is to take on c6 now and
after B takes c6 notice should be the D
takes c6 is absolutely horrific because
after trading Queens we head to an end
game where White has the positional
advantage of the four on three but black
doesn't have a development lead or
anything really to show for it in fact
if anything he's worse when it comes to
development in King safety in addition
to being worse positionally so D takes
c6 doesn't work but after B takes c6 e
five Queen e7 Queen e2 this variation is
one of the sharpest in the Scotch it's
one where white overextends in the
center or to gain space but gives black
targets for the rest of the game being
these e5 and C four pawns both bishop a
six and nine to b6 our main moves here
for black if you want to look into that
another interesting try for wide though
I don't believe it leads to anything
more than equality is this move Bishop
to d3 instead of e5 and after D v e5
Knight g4 we get some sharp positions
that occur all center around the e5 pawn
which is one of the common things about
the mices black going out of his way to
try to win this pawn even with
aggressive moves like g5 but white
having sort of long-term compensation
against blacks weakened and overextended
structure for the rest of the game so
again if we're looking at the scotch
game we see that blacks two main options
Bishop to c5 and Knight to f6 we're
covered here at the classical and the
mices variation giving you the best
general knowledge I can about the
structure as well as the development
patterns the third variation for black
that is a sideline though definitely a
possibility is the Steinitz variation
with Queen h4 which again like Knight f6
is a different way of punishing white
for being overly aggressive in the
center I'm attacking the e4 pawn and if
you want to just defend it I will
continue to increase my pressure taking
advantage of
sort of annoying when you look at the
fact that white doesn't have an easy way
to defend the pawn this guy is pinned
Bishop to d3 would block the Queen's
protection of the night so often we get
very sharp variations where white tries
to flip the script
aka gangster rap style and take
advantage of black leaving his queen
side behind sense alright well I can't
successfully defend the e4 pawn but
we'll see if you end up being happy that
you took this e4 pawn in a few moves
once you have to defend this pawn and
are now struggling with lack of
development and giving me compensation
for the rest of game so this is White's
best approaches this move Knight c3
followed by Knight d2 b5 I guess the
final fourth variation I should mention
because even though it's a sideline is
very solid as the move Bishop before
check the main difference between this
move in the classical is that if I can
induce the move c3 and only then go back
to c5 now in these variations after
Bishop e3 Bishop b6 I don't have to
waste the move Queen f6 to induce III
aka attack the knight to get you to play
this weird move because I've already
induced this pawn to move forward which
could give me some development
advantages when your Knight doesn't get
the most active Square and I haven't
taken away my active square for my
knight giving the best general idea
behind Bishop before check is what I've
done there even though obviously the
theory is certainly more complicated
than that but I hope you enjoyed this
wild ride fast-paced and furious as all
the chess openings are this is design is
an introduction to help kick-start you
in your own opening repertoire maybe
even learn enough to play in tournaments
someday who knows right dream big way to
go kids I'll see you around on the main
site